حسنًا، تم وصف هذه المهمة على أنها
مهمة سلام، ومن المقرر أن يجتمع وفد من الزعماء الأفارقة
مع الرئيس بوتين
اليوم بعد يوم واحد فقط من اجتماعه مع
الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
في كييف، وسمعنا أمس من
رئيس جنوب إفريقيا سيريل رامافوزا
يتحدث إلى جانب
نظيره الأوكراني في  مفتاح الدعوة إلى
وقف تصعيد الصراع من كلا
الجانبين، قائلاً إنه من الأفضل أن
تنتهي الحرب عاجلاً وليس
آجلاً، وبشكل حاسم من خلال
الوسائل الدبلوماسية، أي من خلال المفاوضات، لكن
الرئيس زيلينسكي كان واضحًا جدًا
أين يقف عندما  يتعلق الأمر
باحتمال التوصل إلى اتفاق سلام عن طريق التفاوض، وقد
كرر تلك الرسالة بالأمس
في كييف قائلاً إنه لا يمكن أن يكون هناك
احتمال للتوصل إلى اتفاق سلام عن طريق التفاوض
بينما لا تزال هناك قوات روسية على
الأراضي الأوكرانية، مكرراً دعوته
للانسحاب الكامل والتام للقوات
الروسية.  وفي الوقت نفسه،
سمعنا من المتحدث باسم الكرملين
ديمتري بيسكوف يوم الجمعة أيضًا يقول إن
الرئيس بوتين منفتح على أي
اقتراحات لحل الحرب في
أوكرانيا، واصفًا إياها على حد تعبيرهم بأنها
المشكلة الأوكرانية، لكنه يأمل في التوصل إلى
سلام عن طريق التفاوض، وآمال سيئة في ذلك.  أي
إشارات إيجابية من الرئيس بوتين
اليوم أرلو خاصة بالطبع كما
رأينا القصف الروسي على أوكرانيا
مستمرًا بالأمس حتى من خلال
زيارة وفد الزعماء الأفارقة
بالطبع رأينا أيضًا بعض الأسلحة النووية
من الرئيس بوتين بالأمس
تحدث في سانت بطرسبرغ في المؤتمر
الدولي  المنتدى الاقتصادي يؤكد
أنه تم الآن نشر الدفعة الأولى من الأسلحة النووية التكتيكية في
بيلاروسيا وقد حذر سفير أوكرانيا لدى
المملكة المتحدة الآن من أن
الغرب يجب أن يأخذ هذا الأمر على محمل
الجد الآن بعد البشير في لندن